there's like all these stigmas and kind
of bad stereotypes attached to strippers
and
and dancers i remember asking one of
them
kind of a provocative question like do
you ever go home with people that you
meet in the club you know does that ever
happen just kind of thinking of the
romance and what what could happen at
the end she was like
i'm a dancer i'm not like i'm not an
escort oh i'm sorry no i didn't mean to
insinuate you were
[Music]
hi i'm jennifer lopez i'm one of the
stars and producers of the movie
hustlers and i'm laureen scafaria i'm
the writer director of hustlers and this
is our scene breakdown
[Music]
front hook
ankles now you've learned all of these
moves for this this yes yes this this
was uh choreographed by johanna
that's not right
[Music]
hook yep
knee hook
hold on with that knee okay
come here you can do the carousel
put your head back
come down
destiny ramona have just become friends
and ramona is showing destiny
how to conquer the pole
and ramona is kind of the top money
maker of the club you know she's got it
all figured out yeah she knows all the
moves and she knows how to get away with
doing a lot less
but it's like robbing the bank except
you get the keys
are you in that's the key that's what
everybody wants to know how do i make
the most money doing the less amount of
work that's right that's the american
dream
jesus christ
then you can go into a fairy set
stag
i want to have my heels on all the time
can i wear my heels
now you feel short instead of long and
beautiful you're like short they're
called pleasers for a reason yeah when
you first put them on it's kind of like
you're a baby deer you're walking around
you're fine and all of a sudden you're
like your legs give out and you're like
[Laughter]
i know how to walk in heels and then it
becomes like they're ballet slivers then
you can't do the dance without them
[Music]
we shot in show palace in long island
city this really
well-run strip club that had you know so
much space for us to to work in and i
know people said not to shoot in a real
strip club but i don't think we could
have had it any other way yeah it was so
perfect i know i know it was really
incredible and jane muskie our
production designer added all these
incredible
lights and extended the stage and the
the owner of the club liked it so much
he kept everything
yes he did
reverse stag that's pretty too scissors
is this hard it was very hard
tabletop i can't do that you can do that
you're gonna do that
a climb
we tried to treat it like a stunt in a
way you know have as many cameras going
at once and the pole gets sweaty it gets
you know you're holding it you're
touching you're wrapping your body and
and you start sweating
the alcohol kind of cleans off the pole
so you can grip it or else you'll slip
right off and break your face yeah
what if you don't have muscles to do
that you have muscles to do this i don't
have that every girl has muscles to do
this
the most important thing about the scene
and what
we wanted to get was the friendship
between them that she became like a big
sister to her
she was just like starting out and
taking her under her wing and kind of
teaching her the ropes or the pole
i wanted to make sure that constance
destiny was on stage with her because i
felt like there was this scene before
where ramona was on stage and kind of
separate from destiny and and now
destiny is a part of this journey and so
i just wanted them to play with it and
keep it open you know they have such a
great chemistry together they have such
a great rapport and
really had this this big sister little
sister relationship this was a beautiful
scene to kind of play that out play out
that that dynamic their friendship is is
unique
and i love that this chopin piece is
playing over this to show you you always
had that that was from the very first
script yes that was in there yeah i
remember saying what music is that what
music is that yeah it just shows like
the grace and the elegance of the of the
moves what it what it takes that it's
actually really difficult to do these
things and it takes skill it's not like
any person can just jump up here and do
this no they're athletes the strength
that's required for them to do these
moves and i mean you're a dancer of
course i had a lot of bruises and things
yeah
[Music]
in my own dance and her solo kind of
performance where she goes upside down
the more
really like spinny stuff was was was
harder climbing things like that we've
seen
a scene in a strip club and every single
movie and tv show ever and so few have
been told from the dancer's perspective
so i just wanted to be in their story
and so being in their story naturally
sort of lent itself to the gays there's
a theme of control that runs through it
ramona sometimes decides what the camera
is going to do i like to think she was
always in total
that she wants
the best part of my night was to sit a
man in a bar stool and watch jennifer
and constance and kiki and lily sort of
surround him oh my god turn him into a
puddle that was a real joy
honestly when you bring that talented
group of women like that together
everybody's kind of so full of life and
creative and happy to be there you know
you know that you're in good company
with the cool people and you're like
this is kind of hot this is gonna be a
fun ride there's gonna be something fun
for people to watch
damn
we're a family now
damn a family with money
from the first time i spoke to cardi
about doing the movie i called her and i
told her i said you would know more
about this stuff than i do i said i
would love to pick your brain and what
it's really like to live in this world
because that's what we're trying to
capture
in this movie and she definitely gave
insight into the psyche of what goes on
in an exotic dancer's mind why they do
it and things like that so it was really
helpful
martini martini really does look like a
martini
[Music]
[Laughter]
nothing too dramatic
thanks for checking out our scene
breakdown be sure to get your tickets
for hustlers in theaters september 13th
you can get your tickets on fandango
bye
[Music]